pour être tout à fait complet un peu
d'histoire maintenant quatre fois déjà
dans la vème république
l'assemblée nationale a été dissoute
françoise david
l'article 12 de la constitution est
formel le président de la république
peut après consultation du premier
ministre et des présidents des
assemblées prononcer la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale à quatre reprises
déjà depuis le début de la vème
république
le président a fait usage de ce droit
deux fois pour résoudre des crises
politiques ou sociales
deux fois pour faire coïncider majorité
présidentielle et parlementaire
1958 le général de gaulle devient chef
de l'état quatre ans après à l'issue de
la guerre d'algérie il annonce le
référendum sur l'élection du président
de la république au suffrage universel
mais l'assemblée se rebiffe le
gouvernement pompidou est renversée de
gaulle dissous au peuple de trancher le
différend qui existe entre le
gouvernement et la majorité entre de
gaulle et les parties en novembre 62 les
français choisissent de gaulle
il dispose d'une large majorité mai 68
10 ans ça suffit crient les manifestants
la france est paralysée et la situation
devient insaisissable déclare de gaulle
c'est la dissolution
le chef de l'état gagne son pari lui dr
la majorité absolue la gauche est taillé
en pièces mai 1981 le candidat
mitterrand avait prévenu pas question de
gouverner avec une assemblée nationale
au style u10 où la dynamique
présidentielle joue à plein c'est la
vague rose pour palais bourbon
mais 1988 jacques chirac est premier
ministre
l'assemblée y majoritairement à droite
françois mitterrand a tenté la carte de
l'ouverture politique cela ne marche pas
conséquence logique des élections
législatives et une majorité relative
pour le parti socialiste au palais
bourbon